Yes.
Yesterday we discussed
how a person goes about wiping over
his or her footwear.
The next issue that the author discusses
is the material
of the footwear.
Is it relevant? Does it matter?
And
this is a difference of opinion amongst
the scholars of Islam.
There
are those
who view that the material does in fact
matter.
And furthermore, the style of footwear
matters.
Whilst others
are
of the opinion that the footwear is
irrelevant its style or material.
Any style or material that is worn on
the feet as long as it
covers the majority of the foot, as long
as it fits the criteria
of footwear that the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam wiped over, that is
sufficient.
And so based on this, there are
different sets of criteria that various
scholars have
outlined and mentioned.
But
remember we are
in this sitting trying to
mention only what the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam did or didn't do, and
what his companions did or didn't do.
This is not really a
a discussion regarding the various
opinions of the scholars and why they
arrive at them.
This is geared towards learning the
prophet salallahu alayhi wasallam
sunnah.
And so, based on this, the question that
we must ask ourselves
is based on the evidences
that are cited by the scholars of fiqh
and the scholars of hadith,
is there, in fact, a difference
in the time of the prophet salallahu
alayhi wasallam, did he or his
companions outline
a difference
in material or style of footwear
to distinguish
that which can be wiped over and that
which must be taken off in order to wash
the foot? This is the question that we
want to address.
is literally translated to a sock,
something that hugs the foot
and
is usually made of a material
that is worn with something else.
So, you wear the sock, you don't usually
wear it alone. You wear it and then wear
a khuff over it or you wear it and you
wear a na'l over it, okay? And then we
have a na'l. A na'l
is something that has a sole on
it. It has a separate sole on the
bottom, usually made out of thick hide
or leather
that
you know, now it's usually made out of
rubber or its derivatives or
but
this is the distinction in the Arabic
[Arabic recitation]
Al-Mughirah bin Shu'bah
that
Al-Mughirah said he went to take the
Prophet's
footwear off
so that he could wash his feet, and the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam said,
"Leave them cuz I put them on whilst
having made wudu."
Likewise, Al-Mughirah narrates to us
outside of that incident,
what did the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam used to wipe over? He says,
"The messenger of Allah Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam
was witnessed to have wiped over his
socks and shoes
in
separate incidents. So, he's seen him
wipe over his socks, he's seen him wipe
over his shoes, and he's seen him wipe
over his
his khuffain, made out of leather.
[Arabic recitation]
little bit Omar.
Right in a cat fell off the chain.
Call it a woman who
call it a right in a cat fell off the
chain.
Call it a right in a cat fell off the
Why you have to water via wire? And near
Alice up to you know men and near Alice
up to you know men and women
fear of the Nabi Sallallahu alaihi was
selling women take one Mashhur Mahmoud
Fiji 0 to the Arab in La Calina.
Can I accept my Calista Arab?
Call Satan fee
Arab in Hijaz. Can we have a suit?
I'll call off. Have a lady can Mashhur
then
Mashhur and Mahmoud and
fee of three.
and Jack when I need me Omar and
the Nabi Sallallahu alaihi was selling
La Mesa and now I accept the fee.
We have a little bit of
in the Bay Area fee.
I assume the Cobra and so
here is another narration on the
authority of a bit Omar
in which and now keep in mind where was
a bit Omar during the time of
the tab being
a bit Omar was in Mecca and a bit Omar
was in Medina. He was in that area. He
didn't leave the Arab Peninsula. And so
when would people usually learn from a
bit Omar when they would come for Hajj
or Umrah? They would
meet a bit Omar and collect narrations
from him. From Medina and sometimes when
he would go for Hajj or Umrah in Mecca
and so
they
mentioned to him
some of his students, we saw you do
something that we've never seen anyone
else do. Anyone else meaning any other
companion do or
any other
person do in general.
And he said, "What is that?" He said,
they said, "We see that you wear these
very particular type of shoe.
It's called the Septia. It was not as
common as a Khuffain in the Prophet's
time. We saw you wear this
type of shoe and wipe over it." And he
says that he saw the Prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam wear these shoes
and the style of shoe and wipe over
them.
So when we look at the narrations
we see that there are numerous
narrations of the Prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam himself not making a
distinction
in material or style of footwear when
wiping over them. That's the conclusion
we come to. Now this is just mentioning
the Prophet himself Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. The companions, there are
dozens of narrations of them
understanding this, taking away this
understanding.
Now a person may say
but
in the Madhab
or in the Madhab of
Malik and a Shafi'i and even the Hanbali
Madhab and especially
the Hanafi Madhab it must be a Khuff it
has very specific parameters. Remember
we mentioned that the majority
of the differences of opinions
between the madhahib is not what is
halal and haram.
It is
what is good and better. What is
bad and worse. What and it's rarely an
issue of halal and haram. Second of all,
in a madhhab, to simplify things, the
madhhab is usually choosing one
particular way of doing something or one
particular thing and standardizing it.
[Arabic recitation]
we are discussing is the
actions of the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam and his companions. So, there's
no difference between any of these.
One last thing.
What if a person were wearing dress sho-
socks?
Dress socks. I almost said dress shocks.
Dress
socks.
You know dress socks are supposed to be
really sheen. They're very thin.
Men's dress socks or specially female
dress socks which are even more
delicate, more thin, more sheen. You can
see through them. Does this make a
difference? No. It doesn't make a
difference. Why doesn't it make a
difference? Because
the same
issue presents itself
for the person who's wearing thick socks
and thin socks. For the person who's
wearing sheen socks and
you know
socks that are not transparent.
The same exact issue presents itself.
And what is that issue? Taking off the
washing the feet, putting the socks back
on, putting them back into shoes. This
in itself can present itself as a hurdle
and
a person could do it once, twice, 10
times, 20 times, 500 times in a row
throughout the year wherever they go.
Now it becomes a difficult thing. This
becomes a burden, right? And Islam takes
that into account. That's why we have
this allowance.